All right. Some very interesting comments
and ideas from our audience through the David
Pakman show subreddit. You can find the subreddit@davidpakman.com
slash r e d d t. Now boasting more than 14,000
David Pakman show viewers, one of the largest
independent media subreddits out there.
And there's an interesting question here from
a user called Ian Hourglass, which is David,
can you ask Youtube to make your channel authoritative
and they make a good point, which is we've
been talking about how youtube has been using
this coded language. We are going to prioritize
authoritative news content at the expense
of non authoritative news content. And I've
explained many times we are caught up in this
as non authoritative and thus we are suffering
the consequences that a lot of the conspiracy
channels and others are suffering. So this
is a great idea. If the David Pakman show
youtube channel could be marked as an authoritative
news source by youtube, it would be hugely
beneficial. However, as the first person who
responded to this said, authoritative is not
actually about authority, it's code for corporate
media. And that's why I think it is a great
idea. I would love for our channel to be designated
authoritative for our own benefit, but it's
code for corporate media to the to the greatest
extent that I can tell and thus I don't know
that that's something we can convince youtube
to do.
Also, earlier this week I recommended some
books. It's funny the book segments, when
I recommend books I've read, there never are
that many views for those videos or topics
or clips from the podcast. But a lot of people
will email me and say, David, thank you so
much for the book recommendations, not enough
as discussed just about reading in general,
everybody's stuck in social media and smartphones
and whatever. Thank you for doing it. I bought
this book, I bought that book, a user called
Ferret and engine 91 posted a picture of one
of my recommendations in his hand, Delta v
by Daniel Suarez, which I read. As I mentioned
during my recent vacation in like five days,
I couldn't put it down. Uh, so I will keep
doing it. I think I'll do book recommendations
every two weeks. I have such a back catalog
of books I've never talked about that I can
recommend to you and I'm reading so much these
days that there is going to be no shortage
of material.
And remember that you can go to David pakman.com/recommendations
for a list of my book recommendations, both
fiction and nonfiction. And please, if you
use the links on that page to buy these books,
you help to support the David Pakman show
as well. That is all at David pakman.com/recommendations
and join the discussion on the sub reddit
as well.